[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами пані Ліда і
ведмежатко бо Ми подорожуємо нашу я
абеткою і рухаємося від буквочки до
буквочки і сьогодні у нас нова літера а
яка послухайте будь ласка
вранці півник вкурнику будуть всіх
кукарі-ку Прокидайтеся курчата будемо
букву К вивчати Подивіться будь ласка як
виглядає літера к Ось вона ведмежатко
Таке враження що ніби якісь хлопчик
стоїть і праву ручку підняв догори і
праву ніжку виставив у бік правда схоже
тук-тук схоже схоже вірно давайте з вами
спробуємо написати літеру К за допомогою
нашого пальчика Приготуйте пальчики
і ми пишемо знизу догори паличку
і дві палички у бік угору і вниз і ще
раз паличку зверху донизу простягнули і
серединки Вверх
і вниз скільки паличок ми використали
так три три палички ми можемо взяти з
вами Ось у мене є три фломастера і
скласти з них літеру К
одну покладемо Ось так і дві інші Ось
так ведмедику але Поглянь схоже на
літеру К тук-тук дуже-дуже дуже дуже
навіть схоже і ви спробуєте теж взяти
олівці чи фломастери чи просто навіть
якісь палички і спробуйте скласти літеру
К ви бачите як вона виглядає ніби маєте
таку ніжку в бік виставлену так Гаразд
ось літера к
має звук к Давайте промовимо його к звук
к
приголосний звук ми вимовляємо його з
перешкодою нам наче Щось заважає його
вимовити к і глухо вимовляємо це глухий
приголосний
добре друзі а зараз ми спробуємо з нашим
приголосним к скласти деякі склади
пам'ятаєте як ми це робимо ось першим
буде к і до нього додамо
і і прочитаємо що ми утворили ведмедику
вірно молодець а у вас друзі так
получилося чи ні
Гаразд тепер змінимо голосний і
поставимо інший голосний як він
називається
голосний е Як бачите всі голосні у нас в
нашій абетці позначені червоним кольором
щоб ми пам'ятали що це саме голосні
так і утворився склад ведмедику ке вірно
адже це літера е значить склад буде к
гаразд і давайте
ось такий
поставимо звук і утворимо склад
Прочитайте будь ласка а ми послухаємо
А на голосніше вірно друзі утворився
склад ки
молодці отак можна по черзі утворювати
різні склади з тих літер що ми вже з
вами вивчили Давайте пригадаємо
подумаємо які ж є слова які починаються
на звук к
А ось ми з вами зараз і розкажемо про
звук к і літеру К вона дуже-дуже
господарська У неї на городі ростуть
багато овочів к капуста
к картопля
кабачок а біля будинку у неї росте к
калина
ук криниці чиста Водиця А ще у неї
живуть ведмедики Хто живе Ти бачив Хто
живе тут я бачу к
кошенято
і ще хто к курчата молодець а зараз
давайте складемо з цією літерою слово
ось Подивіться перша літера буде звісно
літера к адже ми про неї вивчаємо
сьогодні
друга літера буде
н ми що до неї дійдемо і обов'язково її
вивчимо
наступне літеру ви вже знаєте точно
і цю ви теж знаєте
і остання теж чекає своєї черги і у нас
утворилося Давай спробуємо прочитати А я
вам друзі допоможу
[музика]
книга
молодці вже так багато літер ви вивчили
з цього слова книга адже ми саме для
того і вчимо літери для того щоб
навчитися читати книжки вірно молодці
друзі а зараз час на загадки
рослина Зелена
несіяна не саджена хто доторкнеться той
обпечеться що це за рослинка така що
може попекти
ніхто її не садить а вона сама собі
росте у лісі
мабуть ви з нею зустрічалися
ведмедику ти знаєш що це за рослинка це
кропива вірно друзі Ви знаєте що кропиву
використовують у лікарських цілях тобто
роблять з неї ліки вона лікувально
рослинка
незважаючи на те що вона трішки і може
попекти нас і у слові кропива теж є
літера к і звук к
наступна загадка послухайте сонечко в
траві зійшло
усміхнулось розцвіло згодом стало
біле-біле і за вітром полетіло це теж
рослинка я вам підкажу спочатку вона
жовтенька кругленька і дуже красива а
потім вона перетворюється на такий Пух
Пушок його можна дмухнути
нас і вона полетить і ця рослинка теж є
лікарською
рослинка Як ви думаєте чи знаєте ви таку
називається ця рослинка ведмедику
кульбаба звісно ти їх бачив багато Так я
бачу бачу такі квітки жовтенькі а потім
вони перетворюються на біленькі вірно
але я не знав як вони називаються Тепер
будеш знати давайте повторимо кульбаба
молодці Ну що ж чи запам'ятали ви слова
у яких є літера к і звук к давайте
повторимо їх кропива
[музика]
к кульбаба
к калина
і овочі пам'ятаєте які ростуть у нашої
літери к к капуста к картопля і живуть
каченя
і ще є у слові морква теж літера к і у
слові котик теж є літера к і звук к Ну
якщо ми вже заговорили про котиків
пам'ятаєте ми з вами вже вчили багато
скоромовок і віршиків про кого Ми вже
вивчили Пригадайте про бобрання
пам'ятаєте ми вчили скоромовку так вчили
і вивчили її про єнота вчили вчили
молодці і про їжачка Ми теж вивчили а
сьогодні нам час дізнатися віршик про
котика і спробуємо його вивчити Гаразд
ведмедику гарно гаразд
скочив котик сів на плотик мої ротик і
животик він біленький і чистенький
гарний Мурчик мій маленький ось такий
коротесенький гарний віршик про Мурчика
котика а зараз ви повторюєте разом з
нами і з ведмедиком готові
Нумо починати
скочив котик ваша черга ведмедику
повторюй скочив котик молодець
сів на плотик Тепер ви друзі
ведмедику
сів на плотик молодець Ми є ротик
мої ротик
і животик і животик Так він біленький
він біленький
і чистенький
гарний Мурчик мій маленький
віршик правда Мені здається що ви
запам'ятали діти Ану спробуємо повторити
цей вірш
скочив котик сів на плотик миє ротик і
животик він біленький і чистенький
гарний Мурчик мій маленький тепер ваша
черга А ми послухаємо з ведмедиком так
ведмедик А ти повторюй за цей час
молодці друзі ведмедику Тепер твоя Чара
очі в котик сів на плотик миє ротик і
животик він біленький і чистенький
гарний Мурчик мій маленький Молодець
ведмедику ти дуже класно повторюєш
віршики Молодець Ну що ж друзі Ви
повторюйте Цей віршик і його
запам'ятайте ще краще А зараз час на гру
ваше завдання
відшукайте серед тих слів які я буду
називати зайве А чому вона зайве
здогадайтесь самі Ось такі слова
капуста кран банан
яке з цих слів тут зайве
ведмедику ти здогадався
[музика]
Мені здається
банан А чому Тому що там немає літери к
ого ведмедику Та ти молодець вірно
правильно друзі якщо ви здогадалися так
само як і ведмедик то ви абсолютно праві
А зараз наступні слова
книга
папір квітка
яке з цих слів тут зайве
ведмедику ти ще не здогадався
ну книга так квітка
[музика]
папір
папір може папір папір вірно ведмедику
адже у слові папір немає літери к і
звука к вірного саме слово папір тут
зайве і ще одна група слів послухайте
лимон камінь курка
Яке ж слово зайве Давайте будемо думати
разом
А ви нам Підкажіть голосно голосно А я
вас почую разом з ведмедиком
А ще голосніше так вірно слово
лимон А вже у ньому немає літери к а які
ви знаєте імена на літеру К і звук к
подумайте А ми підкажемо вам
наприклад
красиве ім'я правда ведмедику Ксеня
Кароліна
Катерина
квітка
А ось є літера к усередині імені Миколка
А ось знов на початку
Костянтин
бачите скільки багато імен і у всіх є
літера к молодці
Ну що ж а зараз час на домашнє завдання
друзі Повторіть будь ласка скоромовки
які ми вже з вами вчили і віршик Про
кого Про кого ми сьогодні вивчили віршик
про котика вірного і Цей віршик про
котика теж повторіть А ми з вами будемо
прощатися Дякую що були з нами і до
нових зустрічей па-па
[музика]
Привіт Привіт друзі Усім привіт з вами
пані Настя і пісенька і юстинка ми дуже
раді вас бачити і давайте з вами
трошечки поспіваємо і порухаємось Нумо
поспіваємо Приготуйте ваші ручки і
пальчики і пальчики і ваш ротик будемо
співати Так ля-ля-ля о супер чудово Ми
сьогодні заспіваємо пісню про
горилу яку знаєте як звали
правильно Юстина її звали Матільда і
жила вона джунглях давайте з вами
вивчимо деякі рухи чи знаєте ви як часу
можуть робити горили
Ось так знаєте як вони бачили колись як
вони Ось так роблять я бачила тата Окей
і ще в нас буде ось такий рух як грати
на гітарі покажіть Так тут тримаємо і
ось тут по струнах ось так даряємо так
граємо перебираємо струни граємо на
гітарі чудово Ось така в нас буде горила
яка вміє співати і грати на гітарі так а
ще коли говорили люблять почухатись то
вони роблять Ось так Так ми будемо
робити коли буде звук у
А ось так коли буде звук а Давайте
спробуємо у Ось так
а а можна по-справжньому почути себе так
А коли буде звук а чухаємо себе ось тут
так по голові готові друзі Давайте
будемо починати вчити
виглядаємо горилу де вона там в тих
джунглях ходить виглядаємо і співаємо ми
в джунглях зустріли
горилу А тепер розб'ємо себе як горила
по грудній клітинці трошки потрошки і
звали горилу матір да А тепер граємо на
гітарі ми тільки так любила співати
пісні і разом з натільдою співали і ми
показуємо на себе і тепер як ми чухались
як горила а у у у а а а
у у у а а а а ау
а а а а Окей добре а тепер давайте все
спробуємо зробити від початку і до кінця
без пауз окей
Давайте починати ми в джунглях зустріли
горилу і звали і горилу
Матільда
метільда так любила співати пісні і
разом з матільдою співали і ми а у у у а
а а а а а ау
ау ау
є суперпопезка яка стоїть чудово були
раді вас бачити па-па па-па
[музика]